said very boldly you could end this
Ukrainian Russia war in 24 hours how so
I know zelinski very well because he was
very honorable with the fake phone call
impeachment hoax number one they said I
made a phone call to him and I was very
threatening I wasn't at all I was
actually very nice I was congratulating
him a victory but when they asked him
they said did you were you threatened he
didn't even know what they were talking
about he was very honorable he could
have done grandstand he said I felt
threatened I felt threatened he didn't
do that and as you know I get along very
well with Putin I would tell Putin got
to settle I would tell zelinski you
gotta settle I would tell one you're
gonna load up with money I tell the
other you're not going to get any money
I would get a settlement in 24 hours now
it should have never happened you have
thousands hundreds of thousands of dead
people right now hundreds of thousands
who have cities that are obliterated I
don't know if you've ever seen the
cities after they finish with the
Rockets you have cities with no building
standing it looks like just a demolition
Zone it's so horrible and you know and
then they'll say two people were hurt no
hundreds of people and thousands of
people were killed you're going to find
out when this whole thing is over that
the number of people killed is far
greater than they tell you they're not
telling you the truth many many
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people are dying these cities are being
obliterated and basically they say
what's your stance are you for Russia or
are you I'm for one thing very simple I
want to stop people from getting killed
and I'll have it stop fast hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else